right now a visitation is underway for
the metro police detective who lost his
life a week ago in a tragic incident by
the centennial bowl in the northwest
part of town 45 year old detective
justin terry was in his police vehicle
when a beam fell on u.s 95 crushing his
vehicle madison kimbrough joins us live
with more information madison
as you can see there are metro police
cars behind me as people show up to pay
their respects for detective justin
terry here at palm mortuary on cheyenne
near buffalo the visitation just got
underway and goes until eight tonight
a visitation will also be held saturday
at palm cheyenne mortuary from four to
eight the department is mourning the
loss of terry he was assigned to the
homicide sex crimes bureau sexual
assault and abuse section he also
started the enduro program at southeast
area command making it possible for
officers to ride dirt bikes into hard to
reach locations to help homeless he was
assigned to the sexual offender
apprehension detail for seven years and
widely regarded as an expert and worked
with the u.s marshals task force terry
was with the police department for
almost 21 years and is survived by a
wife and two sons on monday morning a
police procession will escort the
detective to henderson's central
christian church for the service
starting at 10. the procession will
start at palm downtown mortuary at 8 30
and will travel on the strip and
highways so expect traffic delays around
that time while the service is not open
to the public 8 news now will stream the
service live
there are several fundraisers planned
for detective terry's family from the
injured police officers fund to a
cookout to bracelets and merchandise
there is a website that you can donate
to his family to the funds that's going
to be on our website at 8newsnow.com
reporting near cheyenne and buffalo
madison kimbrough live local now
madison thank you for that